all right okay thank you it is Ladi and
Gentlemen of the committee it is now
post
time
okay um would you all rise so you could
salute the flag
please
repres representative har thank you
please join with me in a pledge to our
flag I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands nation
under God indivisible liberty and
all this yours or mine that's mine
that's yours okay mine might be over
here or or yours might be over there you
can just use mine okay
uh just want to welcome everybody to the
uh executive session on
uh on four
bills uh we're going to try to do them
in order we also have uh at we're this
is at 10 o'clock
uh we also have at 4
10:45 uh a hearing on a non- gerine
amendment in 4 House Bill
452 and then we will go into executive
session on on that 47 472 excuse me and
then we will go into executive session
on
that which I think is around here
somewhere all let me let me get started
on uh the executive session on House
Bill
186 relative to waivers for alternative
Systems represent representative veiled
you
uh for a
motion thank you Mr chair I make a
motion of itl on House Bill
second second by representative
Darby do you wish to speak on your
motion representative Veil yes Mr chair
thank you um so house bill was 186 was
um filed in order
to see if there was a legislative
solution that would would help Grafton
County to be able to um reduce the
amount of the percentage of their um
taxes that go toward um the sewer
company that they're using right now so
25% is a
lot um but what we found during the
hearing was that the legislative
solution um does it would impact Other M
municipalities in a negative
way and time to get this changed was not
available to the sponsor or to the
committee the bill needs to address to
go forward um concerns raised by Dees
about water quality and also um there
was opposition from New Hampshire bir
New Hampshire Rivers um because of the
cyano bacteria blooms and other
bacterial um infections that happen on
our water bodies so we do want them to
be able to address the issues that
they're having but again this bill has
too many negative impacts for us to go
forward with it and so we're hoping that
a non-legislative solution might be more
helpful but if not then we could um help
them with another Bill thank you Mr
chair do you wish do you wish to speak
to your second I have nothing further to
add thank you Mr chair nothing further
is there anyone from on the uh on the uh
committee who wishes to speak on this
bill seeing no one on House Bill 186
will the clerk please call the rooll oh
by the way be before we start the roll
call we do have four uh
substitutes uh representative
Boyd uh representativ
spear representative
Raymond
Raymond they do it loudly and uh the
other
representative oh oh yes representative
kraton just like always welcome back
welcome back to the committee I know you
could I knew you couldn't stay away
former Committee Member but he he left
him will the clerk please call the role
yes certainly thank you Mr Mr chair
representative harb
yes representative Boyd yes
representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
hi representative wolf yes
representative
MCU
yes uh representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative Rong yes
representative Kelly
yes representative Raymond
yes representative uh Baldwin
yes representative Derby yes
representative ho yes representative
lontine yes representative spear yes
representative Ryan yes and
chair yes 20 to Zer unanimously
passed representative is there any uh
any problem with
consent seeing
none it be consent calender 20 to
nothing itl
passes it's itl is itl uh moving on to
House
Bill 194
FN requiring the director of the vision
of archives and Records management to
compile a m and maintain a list of
public monuments chair
recognizes uh recognizes the the vice
chair har thank you Mr chair motion I'd
like to move itl on 194
FN is there a second I'll second second
by by represent of Harvey bolia is do
you like to speak to your Mo yes thank
you Mr chair uh I think this bill as
currently written still has some issues
regarding definitions and compilation
and other problems I also reviewed the
record and it appears to me that much of
what the prime sponsor wish to do can be
done without a bill and can be easily
done by the um Division and so I would
you representative Harvey Bia do you
have a uh wish to speak on your second I
have nothing to add
okay uh rep rep repres representative
mchu would you wish to speak thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr chairman while
I do support the idea of expanding our
historical catalog and the resources
available to students I'm I'm forced to
read the prime sponsor's email from
yesterday that talks about all the
confusion that has plagued this process
beginning with my I'm just I'm quoting
beginning with my mistake and
identifying the wrong Department to do
the work and he goes on and
mentions that uh while I can dream that
the in the future we'll have some
federal dollars that the department
could use to build out the website as a
more robust educational and research
tool sounds like a great idea he goes on
especially with federal dollars he goes
on I worked with director Wilson
specifically to make this project fit
within the work already done by his
Department without the need for
additional resources I I happen to sit
on another commission with director
Wilson and engaged him on this very
topic and basically said would you like
us to pass this bill or not do you need
it to do this work are you going to do
the work anyways and the answer was
indifferent don't need it to do the work
and I'm happy to do it anyways um
because it's something it's part of what
we already do so in my view the Bill's
not necessary and the work's still going
to get done so that's what I have to
add anyone else wish to speak on the
bill rep repres representative Darby
then representative
Rong thank you Mr chair um in the
original testimony we heard how um from
uh from numerous supporters how um the
collection of this information would
help um students in the state um and and
highlight um some of the uh some of the
historical um mon monuments that um are
are supported or provide or sponsored I
guess supported by the local
municipalities but just not known um by
throughout the greater State um in the
work session um we talked about I think
it was a work session we talked about
how um getting broader awareness of
those monuments is is in everyone's best
interest I definitely appreciate um you
know the the director's um desire maybe
to to implement this on you know on his
own behalf but he hasn't done it yet so
I'm I'm skeptical that it'll actually
happen without some some
encouragement now we know that the um
that the original Bill had some flaws
and so you've seen on the table in front
of you an amendment that really
addresses a lot of those flaws um I will
point out that back in um January the
chair um emailed um the committee um an
an email from uh the director Benjamin
Wilson that he stated um could be read
into the record and I believe that it
was read into the record and
specifically it said um I want the
committee to know that I support that I
and the division of historical resources
support the bill have worked with a
sponsor um and that we can accomplish
the bill without any burden to DHR staff
the division of historical resources
staff or committing Financial Resources
so if the if we if we um if we um fail
this itl motion don't pass this itm
motion and um let another uh motion
stand I think we can U make some good
progress in this state with historical
you representative rung for thank you Mr
chair stat I Echo what my colleague from
nashwa has said um but I also want to
bring up a point of order it's seems as
though all the discussion on this motion
is on the amendment which hasn't been
introduced yet so um I I'm going to be
voting no on the itl motion so that the
amendment can be brought forward since
that seems to be the topic of discussion
and it was the topic when the
subcommittee
met you are correct this is on the bill
as uh as
presented uh and the so the uh amendment
is not on the the table so uh please uh
focus on the bill as uh in the dis this
discussion and the bill
as presented as as
Vale thank you Mr chair I'm speaking as
the um subcommittee
chairperson
chairman
um the original bill
goes to the wrong department and it has
a fiscal note that consulted with the
wrong
Department I received the email
from um the repres from Ben Wilson some
time back and went over these things to
me they could be addressed in an
amendment and the subcommittee spent a
lot of time discussing what the
amendment would look like if it were to
be different than and the one that we
are about to introduce hopefully on a
different
motion um but this is an amendment that
was written in January and IT addresses
most of the concerns of the bill we feel
that it could be restricted to a list
and just to say that we didn't hold a
vote as a subcommittee because we really
didn't make any kind of significant
progress on um some of the questions
that we had so as a followup to that um
subcommittee hearing what we did was
send out that list of questions that
came up um during the subcommittee and
we um got some answers back um long
after we adjourned that so just to
reiterate we did not vote what we did
was we decided to support the amendment
and hope for an overturn of an itl so we
could get to the other motion and um
talk about where this puts the um the
statute in the right area and Consulting
the right director of the right agency
in terms of compiling public
monuments um I just mentioned and I'll
keep on mentioning that I think um the
subcommittee members all agree that
history is really important this is part
of our lifestyle in New Hampshire the
fact that we have a long long history
that we can go back to we can see all
the twists twists and turns that we've
taken and all of the people that helped
to shape New Hampshire to be what it is
today for the good and for the bad so um
I look forward to hopefully getting on
to another motion on this bill and um
chair represent repres representative
for the second time thank Mr chairman
just wanted to bring to the committee's
attention the director's response to one
of our Representatives questions by
email um who asked can the Bill's intent
be accomplished by rules versus
legislation and his answer to that was
it all depends on how the project is
defined if the nhhr is simply hosting a
list of public monuments by town on a
web page no legislation is
needed he goes on to elaborate um about
having enabling legislation for an
administrative rule such as the NH hdhr
shall maintain a list of public
monuments that would require an
amendment to RSA
227c yes administrative rules reviewed
and adopted every 10
years so by my interpretation of this
and speaking directly with the director
he doesn't need this legislation to do
what the original Bill's asking or even
I haven't seen I just took a quick
glance at the amendment but I haven't
seen the actual Amendment and I know
we're going to debate that separately
but I I see from the prime sponsor and
the director of the department
that it's the work's going to get done
and everybody values it but we don't
need to pass the law to do it maybe I'm
reading it wrong but that's how I read
it anyone else wish to speak on the uh
motion seeing
none look Qui please call the
rooll yes thank you um the motion of on
the motion of it yes thank you on 19 for
FN representative harb yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Horgan yes CL votes yes representative
kraton I representative wolf yes
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative dun yes
Representative
veale no representative rung
no represent restive Kelly no
representative Raymond no representative
Baldwin no representative Darby no
Representative hoit no Representative
lontine no representative spear
no representative uh Ryan no and the
chair yes yes that is
by a vote of 10- 10 the motion
fails
uh representative rung for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move that we accept
amendment number
d00
37h uh representative could you first
make a motion on the uh
on uh oh okay I move on the bill Mo a
motion okay I move that we
um vote ought to pass on um HB 194 FN
okay now I'll accept the motion to an
amendment okay um I move do I need a
second on the motion no it's right I do
need a second
okay
second oh oh
okay okay okay uh thank you Mr chair now
I move that we accept amendment number
2023 0037 H which was distributed um
during the executive session when this
retained okay do you wish to speak on
the amendment probably do I need a
second for that oh yes you
do everybody please uh anybody wants a
vot yell Out Mr do we have copies do we
have copies of the amendment I hear you
usually a lot Mr chairman do we have
copies of the amendment I know it was
distributed in January but uh do that
was a while ago I had
some let see if I can find some
here can you repeat the please yes
madame clerk it's
d00
37h I have sub copies here does anybody
need some uh you pass that down anybody
else need a some
copies
okay we got at least three I think I've
got some more I think I actually made a
bunch of copies back in this back in
January figuring we'd be we wouldn't be
here anybody else want some
way
more
I didn't thought I I thought they were
going to be starting a
not all right is everybody why don't to
again is everyone uh everybody ready to
go on the discussion of the
amendment uh representative
thank you Mr chair the amendment thank
you I realize we've already had some
discussion um with the previous motion
but I want to reiterate that the flaws
that were in the original Bill have been
corrected with this amendment um the
intent is been placed with the proper
Department within the state government
um we've already heard um through email
and um I think phone calls from that uh
director of the division that he
supports this amend amendment that this
is work that he feels is very
appropriate and would not come at an
additional cost um during the
subcommittee meeting we had discussions
about some of the terminology that was
used like how do we Define monuments but
in other areas of the statute historical
markers and historical monuments are
already um defined I I think um we can
overthink this too much I think this is
really just um assigning a
responsibility to a department that's
appropriate to to them with no added
cost it's something that they haven't
done yet and getting to representative
Darby's comment if they haven't done it
yet I I'm not sure whether they would do
it without having um a bill come before
them so I encourage everyone to um
support this amendment thank
you representative Darby for uh talk to
you second thank you Mr chair just Bri
briefly um the amendment corrects the
intent of the bill it was um as the uh
as the prime sponsor mentioned in his
original testimony due to his you know
his
novice uh uh in introducing the bill he
directed at the wrong Department this
simply corrects the department which
ultimately um you know will help with
the the financial um justification it's
even if you don't support the concept
supporting the amendment makes sense
because it it's it aligns with the
intent of the bill so I urge you to vote
amendment represent representative Vil
chair sorry for the delayed response I
just remembered that I didn't talk about
the amendment because I was trying not
to talk about the
amendment but you did talk about but I
talked about them anyway but not as much
as I would have um so just that this
bill um the amendment here it fixes to
the division of historical resources and
um it's to the correct department we
know that this bill can be executed
without a fiscal note and um we know
that time is of the E Essence with
history I think about this all the time
that when you're 16 17 198 and you're
studying history that year that you miss
or that
that thing that you weren't able to do
because the legislature killed it would
be something that would stay with you
for the rest of your life and history is
really important that way because it has
like an exponential prop propagation
it's really up to us to make sure that
we're transmitting our history um in all
the ways that we do and to line up with
what we say we do here for education in
New Hampshire so I'm really hoping that
people will go ahead and vote yay on the
amendment and vote for a motion to ought
to pass as amended and we can send this
to the floor and pass it there thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
amendment specifically on the
amendment uh I the chair would like to
speak a little bit on the amendment
first of all uh the chair and and the
ranking member got into issue on whether
on whether or not this bill uh this
amendment was actually Germaine because
it actually changed the uh uh part of
the uh this the part of the statutes
that uh from the that the that that
we've that is that is taken care of this
issue it goes from one part of the
statute to another uh we did uh we went
did we did uh go to the clerk and who
consulted the speaker and the speaker
ruled that this it is Germain and that
it is uh it is correcting really a a an
error uh in drafting and not uh in and
not actually making a a change in uh uh
in where the where the uh it's going to
where it's supposed to go at any rate so
it is it is simply an error so that's
why it was uh it's being accepted as a
Germain Amendment uh the ALS also but
there there while this
amendment does correct that that issue
on on who does who is supposed to do the
work it really is in still still is
still incomplete uh for instance uh just
looking at it uh uh just cursory it uh
talks about physical markers of a
historical event individual groups uh
geographical sites of historical
cultural
significance don't we have a don't we do
that right now what is the the uh the
director of the division of historic
resources there are these signs all over
about this is a this house or this
person was born here or there are there
are several in front of uh uh in front
in front of this these very
buildings uh so and those are those
lists do are available and there that
exists now so it's just it's
just uh a a duplication of effort we
already we already have it done it's
already been done it's already been paid
for so at least at least that segment is
and so but that's again that's part of
the the the the defects that are still
in the in the exist in the bill so I
will be I will be supporting the
amendment simply because it does change
the uh the the change the uh clerical
issue of it this going to the wrong
uh division so it's at least at least it
will get that in the record
so will
the uh in that is there any other
uh this anybody else wish to speak on
the on the
issue represent representative mchu
thank Mr chairman just a a quick
parliamentary question a true
parliamentary question if the amendment
fails then the next vote is ought to
pass on the original Bill and should we
wish to amend it it would have to be
done as a floor Amendment
correct
yes assuming yeah assume sorry assuming
it goes to the floor and the vote goes
the way the previous votes did it has to
be without recommendation yes okay so it
would go without recommendation
recommendation and to amend it would
require a floor Amendment yes to amend
the original bill that had all those
problems right if this if this bill if
this amendment passes this would uh this
bill would be the committee's
amendment or this amendment would uh uh
would be the committee
Amendment so further question so the
alternative would be vote down the
amendment and it would have to come as a
floor
Amendment it would thank
you
questions that
will on the amendment will the clerk
rooll yes uh Mr chair on the amendment
for
20233 7h ra uh representative harb yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
representative Kon I representative wolf
yes representative MCU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative Rong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Raymond yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
ho yes representative ltin yes
representative spear yes representative
Ryan yes and the
chair yes that's 20 to zero passes okay
amended is there any dis uh do I have a
uh do I have a
motion representative R thank you Mr
chair um I move ought to pass as amended
on hb1 194
FN is there a
second representative L Montaine seconds
you wish to speak to your motion well
we've had a lot of discussion on this
we've had a subcommittee and this I just
want to reiterate this bill came to us
from an esteemed history professor at
keing State College who saw the need for
this um function as part of state
government that could be used and as a
resource to students and teachers
throughout the state I know we get kind
of caught up in the Weeds about what
does this mean what does this mean those
in my opinion are minor issues that can
be ironed out as the bill if it passes
into log gets implemented by the
division of historical resources so I
think for the good of students and
teachers in the state um we should move
forward to get this resource available
thank
you representative lontine for a speak
on a
second yeah I'll just briefly add that
um it may be true that the division
already has lists and and what we're
asking in this bill is uh within the
purview and scope of the divisions work
but the key difference is making the
list in the survey of available to the
public and educational
institutions that's the difference and
it won't really cost any more money to
do
that
thanks anyone else wish to speak on the
on the representative Ryan thank you um
yes also to review the list every 10
updated uh is there anyone else who
wishes to speak on the motion
representative
derby um thank you Mr chair um just
because it's been a while since we heard
the original testimony I just wanted to
remind um the committee that we heard
from um a former history teacher who
talked about an a a national competition
where he believes that um a National
History competition where he believes
that New Hampshire students are at a
disadvantage because they don't have
access uh to resources such as this and
that he thought that this would be um
helpful in in them competing and so you
know for like as was mentioned um for
the students um for preserving history
in uh uh um promoting history across the
state I urge otpa on um uh House Bill
194 as amended thank you there anyone
motion pres veale thank you Mr chair
only to say that um with this amendment
this is the bill there's no doubt in my
mind that we need this bill in order to
accomplish what we want to um offer and
what we want our state's agency to offer
to students in New Hampshire and their
families thank you Mr
chair there anyone else who wishes to
speak to this bill or I ought to pass as
amended representative of wolf thank you
Mr chair and there is no cost on
developing this bill uh well that's
what's been stated well let's see why
don't we add look let's consult the
amendment do you see anything in the
amendment that talks about no costs to
this bill did you see it there no
however you do have in the original
Bill the uh that says there is a cost or
at least there is an FN on it so I
recommend and I'm going to recommend to
the speaker no matter what happens to
this bill that it goes to finance
because that is on there and we we have
we get all we have that says there's no
cost to this
bill is the words of someone who did not
show up on four occasions to tell us
that
down okay so I once its happenstance
twice its circumstance three times it's
enemy action thank you what four times
you tell
me at any rate I will believe it when
Finance tells me that there no cost to
this
other than that that is why well put it
issue that I'm answering your question
on that specific issue so there is an FN
attached to this bill and it goes along
with this bill because this amendment is
for that
bill so not change that is my question
is the FN stay with the bill or does it
Disappear by having this amendment which
changes the bill it changes the bill but
it does not so I as I see it change any
ver any uh anything having to do with
the
uh uh the finances of the bill the bill
the amendment speaks for itself
representative Derby and then
representative um
um we did receive a finan fiscal note
for this and it came you know they had
consulted the original department on it
so I'm not questioning I'm definitely
not questioning the chair in that you
know that it would be worthwhile to to
get a revised fiscal note but revised
fiscal note is definitely warranted
because it's a different department and
the um
the the office that um that res resolves
the fiscal notes would have to consult
Department representative thank you Mr
chair um yes I want to specify that the
fiscal note as representative Darby said
was on the original bill because the
department that would have assumed this
responsibility had because this wasn't
in their their duties would have to hire
someone and that if you go back to the
original Bill and look at the fiscal
note that was the reason the department
of archives and Records management would
have to hire someone to do this but with
the amendment and this responsibility
now goes to the division of historical
resources they already have the staff to
do it so on those several occasions
where the director of historical
resources has responded by email
regarding this bill he stated there is
no fiscal note that's going to be
required now I'm all for supporting this
bill going to finance and for them to
hear it directly um but our role Now is
really to vote on the policy that's
presented through the amendment the
reason there is an FN is that Finance
can then weigh in but we can pass this
bill as amended and if by some trance
there's some fiscal note whether it's a
dollar $100 or whatever we're going to
learn that from Finance anyway and the
bill will come back so I think what our
duty is now is to um vote on what the
intent of this bill is which is to
compile a comprehensive list of
historical information that students and
teachers throughout the state can access
and to keep more importantly to make
years representative M then represent
representative har thank you Mr chairman
I think perhaps now when I look back at
the original bill and see that it
mentions division of archives and
records and the amendment is directed at
director Wilson's division of historical
resources that could be why he didn't
didn't turn up initially until he was
involved in the
conversation via
email um so my perspective on this bill
has changed a little bit in that it's he
said he he's going to have a staffer
send an email
to compile this list it's not a big
fancy website and I'm confident that
finance will figure it out if it is and
if there's a cost they'll attach that
cost so it's a good idea to have the
fiscal note I agree with that but as the
amendment's written it's a
it's say harmless but it's it's a it's
not that impactful because they plan to
do it
already and they say they they say they
have the staff and potentially it's a
resource for for
educators I mean I agree there are still
a few problems in terms of defining some
of these specific things but I I'm
itative Har um thank you Mr chair again
I'm going to Repeat based upon director
Wilson's email that uh I don't believe
we should pass a legislation that's not
necessary required and since it's been
brought up a number of times in this
discussion the bill as amended says
every 10 years I think the director will
do it more frequently than every 10
years and it doesn't need to be in
you anyone else wish to speak on the uh
bill only a few only a few
things I will speak on a couple of
things there are more many things
there's no definition of at all of
monument I don't where maybe there's
something in there it is in in statute
it is not in this bill
the much of the much of what's being
asked to go in this in
this in this bill already exists in
other forms so the nobody's being denied
any
information uh there are
things that are of Great Value but it
don't necessarily have markers or
monuments one of the greatest things of
value we have is the Hall of flags
should that be
here I would think
so is there a marker a monument when it
or is that in of itself a monument is
monument you got to have to Define
things and when someone when a when
someone a division a director
says oh well I can find somebody to do
it well what is that person doing
now if that person is
not that that's that especially when you
could start making that statement in
front of Finance first thing I think
they would go say well what are you
doing now with with the money that what
is that person doing now and are you
going to have to increase that person's
work or is that person not being used
appropriately those are all questions
that usually that's why you have a
financial thing and that's why it's it's
just supposed to be
discussed it should be discussed we
shouldn't we shouldn't be putting
together a an amend a a law that has too
many questions in it and this has too
many questions it is
it's too it's where we where you get in
trouble with statutes is when there's no
no there's a a lack of
definity
and laws get laws get get on the books
that people say well that isn't what we
should be doing but eventually that's
what happens we need specificity this
this there is there is definitely a
requirement for more work to this
Bill not I'm against it not but that's
that again that's my uh that's my
position represent representative Spire
hi uh in in the amendment it says that
every uh 10 years the director of
division of historical resources shall
work with local communities throughout
the state and it seems to me that it's
the local communities that will that
will decide what is a monument and what
is not we have a lot of monuments at the
state level and some formal monuments
around but local communities made toine
monuments it I think they're free to
Define them as they choose and that's
what would go on the list so I don't
know that you have to Define everything
so much as allow the local communities
to Define what they feel is important
just a comment okay but uh I think we've
had uh enough debate on Up For the First
Time representative Don thank you chair
um I have just a quick question uh
regarding this if the director of the
the division of historical resources um
does not do this is there any
consequence doesn't is if he doesn't do
the every 10 years if he doesn't make
the email if he doesn't follow the bill
what's the consequence of him not doing
this there's no there's nothing in this
bill that says there there's no
consequence for him to do do this so
it's still up to him correct me if I'm
wrong whether or not he chooses to do
this going back to the original
statement of saying this will force him
to do this he still has the choice not
to do this if he doesn't have the
correct that's that is
a there's there
is precedence for people not doing
what's been asked of the of of them to
do in statute but then we have the
ability to go try to get that taken care
of there is a hierarchy in the executive
branch for that there are people from
the executive branch but I I won't ask
you that question if we tell you if you
if there's something in a statute and
you don't do it what happens
well I think I know I think we already
know I won't ask that that I won't but
that's about the best answer I think I
can give represent resentative Derby for
State all I was going to say is that
that's where the judici judicial branch
um resolves disputes between the um
legislative and the executive
branches representative
wolf listening to all the testimony
today and knowing how I look at those
green markers that are out there and I'd
love to have a few more leads on other
markers that may not be one of the state
bill all
other any other discussion any other if
not we a clerk please call the
role thank you Mr chair
on 194
dfn as amended representative har
no representative Boyd
no representative
Horgan no CL votes no representative
Healey I mean uh Bron
nay representative wolf
yes representative mchu
yes representative donelly yes
Vil
yes
representative run
yes representative eeman
yes representative Raymond
yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine
yes representative spear
yes representative Ryan yes and the
S 13 13
to
with
it
three okay is uh who will write the uh
majority
actually Mr chair I'll be happy to write
the majority report well I should say
they well they actually you know ought
to pass it passes uh I should say uh 194
is passed as
amended uh and majority report yeah will
be
uh written by representative
rung when do you need it Mr chair oh
right now okay I'm kidding uh we uh end
of day no just could probably could
be beginning of the of sale on Monday
Monday okay I'll get it through wait a
minute say say Friday give it to uh I'll
give it to the ranking member Friday and
who'll get it to you up okay okay and uh
Report y yeah bail you have
a yes just procedural yep so when the
bill comes down down to the floor this
is going to be the committee Amendment
do we have to speak to the bill as it
was written and then get the
amendment no usually it'll it will it
will be the same way any other bill goes
to the floor it goes to the floor as uh
ought to pass uh but you there is you
there is always a second vote on the
amendment but usually that's a uh that's
a
that's you know the if you notice the
first
vote in uh it comes to the speaker is an
ought it's an ought to pass and then
there and then you there's a vote on
this on the committee Amendment so this
is the committee of M Mr Mr chairman
thank you that clarifies parliamentary
clarification on that I I I believe the
first vote on the floor of the house is
on the committee report which is now
ought to pass as amended right with the
the approved committee amendment was
passed here so the first vote on the
floor I believe is ought to pass as
amended after that passes or fails it
would be open to further Amendment or
further motion if it failed right so the
the vote is O the the floor vote is OTP
as amended it's it's actually a vote on
the committee report yeah but I think
you he's stuck in the middle is a uh
well it's it's open to further right
open to further Amendment once this
passes but we have to this the committee
report would have to be
defeated first or acted on I should say
acted on first but the committee report
is ought to pass as Amendment correct so
so you could it could be if it passes
it's open to further Amendment if it
fails it's open to another motion yeah
which could be anything
okay that answer your question it does
it actually answers my question because
I was wondering what representative
Run's committee report would look like
should it look like the bill B and are
we allowed to address the amendment in
the committee report so that we can get
okay unless it goes to the floor as a 10
to 10 but we don't have a 10 to 10 here
anymore okay great just a lot of mental
okay okay that's we're done okay we uh
Minority Report is me anything
House Bill
398 chair
recognizes representative Vale who is
the chair of the
subcommittee on this
Bill thank you Mr
chair um as we we met um we went over
the
amendment we wanted to make sure that um
the warning
about p is consistent throughout the
language we didn't wanted to make sure
that a notification didn't stray from
language that the federal government is
using and so there was an agreed upon
um I think our vote was four to zero
there was
one sent uh one word that this primary
sponsor wanted to
change but we really talked that through
and decided that um it's okay to just
continue to call them substances and not
necessarily chemicals at this stage of
the game so we would want to continue to
do
that um so basically I will let um
representative
Darby further explore the work of the
subcommittee and um to make a
motion um well I'll decide if he makes
it representative Darby thank you Mr
chair um I'd like to make a motion ought
398 okay and and for a you want a speak
uh you want to make you make another
motion on second nether second okay the
second by representative site see
spe and uh on
the yeah she she made the second she she
yeah and uh on the amendment you want to
okay motion on the amendment um thank
you Mr chair yes I'd like to um make a
motion to amend House Bill 398 with
Amendment
d229
6h for an amendment or excuse me on for
a
second second ago wait a minute you
can't make the second she mve second we
have main motion I don't she yeah well
she can't second anyway uh
took need to go
back
that's okay representative Ryan for
seconds on
both
yeah no yeah you're if you're a sub you
can't second or make
motions you just vote Mr Mr chairman
point of order don't we don't we vote on
the amendment first yes that's what
we're okay but the motion was not to
pass yeah okay there should be did you
mean ought to pass on the amendment I I
think now he makes the motion first
ought to pass then he goes back
immediately moves the
motion you have to have the Au to pass
on
yeah Mr chair would um may I ask the
clerk to read who made the motion and
who seconded on the OTP and then also on
the amendment since there appears to be
some
confusion I mean I've crossed it out um
all right I had Darby Spear and then
Darby and Ryan I'm not sure where we
wanna go uh it's gonna be I'm both it's
going to be
Darby and Ryan on
boat
okay all right on the
uh you want to speak to your
Amendment uh thank you Mr chair yes on
the amendment um so this amendment um
makes some changes to um to House Bill
398 that were discussed at the original
hearing um the original hearing had uh
the original Bill had two sections a
notification um Clause into purchase and
sales and also a change to disclosure um
related to um letter that um that
homeowners may receive from Dees there
was much concern from both uh the
Department of Environmental Services as
well as the Realtors on the disclosure
portion of this um and there there was
some cleanup work on the um on the
notification which is basically um
alerting the intent of the notification
is alerting um uh home buy home buyers
of the potential of um of pasas in their
well and encouraging well water
encouraging them to uh to get it tested
so this um this amendment was um drafted
to repair those deficiencies also to
update the um the effective date to
align with uh the the realtor's
timetable um and we discussed this at a
sub subcommittee um with the prime
sponsor um the Department of
Environmental Services um and the
realtor um representative all in
attendance um and the um Department of
enviral Services um supported it the
prime sponsor supported it and the uh
Realtors um were not opposed to it um a
as such we voted it was unanimously uh
supported in the um subcommittee and I
would um ask for your support um in
passing this amendment thank
you Mr chairman just for clarification
the record can representative Derby if
he hasn't already done it but I didn't
hear it recite the amendment number oh
sorry I I I did do it when I announced
it but I'll do it again my apologies
6h you wish to speak on your second
representative r on the amendment no Mr
Derby covered everything thank you
anyone else wish to speak to the uh
Amendment seeing none on the amendment
report please call the
rooll thank you on the amendment for
House Bill
398 representative harb yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Horgan yes clerk votes yes
representative kryon I representative
wolf yes representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
veale yes representative brong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Raymond yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
hoit yes representative lontine yes
representative spear yes representative
Ryan yes and the
chair yes that is 20 to
zero on ought to pass as
seeing
none clerk please call the
rooll yes Mr chair on House Bill 398 as
amended representative harp yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Horgan yes CL votes yes representative
Kon I'm representative wolf yes
representative
MCU yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
veale yes representative Ron yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Raymond yes representative Baldwin
yes representative Darby yes
representative Hoy yes representative L
Montaine yes representative spear yes
representative Ryan yes and the chair
yes and that's 20 to
zero Mr chairman I'd ask
consent I Bill
398 20 to nothing passes as ought to
consent uh
now House Bill
[Music]
434 representative Derby for a for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
make motion itl on House Bill
434 have motion of itl by representative
second I see representative Vale uh you
wish to speak on your motion yes thank
you Mr
chair um so we heard during the original
testimony from the uh director of the
division of U Parks and Rec how um they
were concerned that this bill may lead
to to um disturbances of the public
trying to use the the parks um and
really um uh subverting the expectation
of a quiet experience as they're parking
and recreate um hiking and recreating um
in the Parks um they also uh found some
concerns with some of the language in
the bill itself for example um that the
intent um of uh the
intent um of disturbing the public was
was not enforceable um and they pointed
out that there is an existing permitting
process for special uh for special use
commercial uses um that that exists and
that um that UAV uh operators can use
the New Hampshire aabon um Society also
expressed concerns that this would lead
to the use of uh amateur operators um
and disturbing sensitive spe uh species
in particular leading potentially
leading to birds abandoning their nest
nests and finally we also heard from the
Department of uh Transportation
Aeronautics who said that the um the
language in the original bill um was not
in line with um the um Aeronautics uh
language um from from other parts of
statue um and expressed some concerns
about um uh Landing in um costs for
landing in emergency situations as well
as um uh as well as uh the some terms in
there with use of the airspace and that
that not actually regulated by the state
um altogether the the bill is um has
many concerns for the use of our our our
precious natural spaces and um and as as
drafted is is really not ready for um to
be passed so I urge itl on House Bill
you is would you like to speak you like
to speak to your a
second um yes thank
you so this is the second time this
matter has come before us and I want to
say that it's heading in the right
direction because we are talking about
specific uses um in specific parts of
the park system um looking to me I'm
really happy to see within the amendment
that the Canon Mountain ski area during
operating hours so there's some of
voidance of safety problems that we
could
foresee um when frankon and Notch is
really mobbed with tourists so I do
think that a lot of work happened on the
first bill this one was the second bill
um and it has some better features in it
we talked about how they do this in
other states and we talked about that so
last week we had the state parks
advisory commission hearing the um and
also known as
spec and the people that attend are
stakeholders um in the park system uh
there are people from Industries um like
the ohvs and people that run um the
state park at Hampton Beach so you're
really thinking about a broad swath of
different kinds of parks that we have
their concerns were that you know they
just they feel like they're some of this
could be um addressed in Ru making
Authority but the other thing that they
wanted you know was maybe more reason
why we would need to do this in light of
the fact that you can get a a temporary
use permit um but anyway to just make a
long story short there wasn't a lot of
appetite for this at the State Park
advisory committee and they did raise um
some questions that should be addressed
such as um where what states are doing
this and how are they doing it
successfully they want to see what the
impact would
be probably in advance of venturing into
having drones or uavs in state park so
second anyone else wish to speak on the
motion representative m sorry I'm
confused the motion is itl right it
sounded like the representative was
speaking on on an amendment that I
didn't know whether I didn't think it
was offered yet that is
true there is a there there would have
to be a a repeat of the
amendment excuse me a defeated of the
motion in order to be able to take up
the
you that probably should not have
discussed the amendment
no um my apologies for that that was out
of order um I think I could have made it
more simple by just saying that the work
that's being done is going in the right
direction and it is being taken
seriously but it's not ready yet and
in any other dis any other discussion
representative Rong Mr chair I'm a
little confused so the um the motion on
the floor is it
yes it is so if the majority of the
committee approves that motion the bill
is going to the floor as in expediate to
legislate so I'm not really sure when
the opportunity to bring the amendment
would come in the opportunity at that
point the opportunity would be as a
floor Amendment okay thank
you at first that would have to be
itl
anyone
else seeing none will the clerk please
call the rooll on the motion of itl yes
thank you Mr chair on the motion of itl
on 434 fiscal note representative harb
yes representative Boyd yes
representative Horgan yes cler votes no
representative kraton
I representative wolf yes
representative MCU no
oops all right representative Donnelly
yes representative dun yes
no Mis voted the motion on the floor is
itl my vote is yes thank you for
clarifying representative Bale votes yes
representative run yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Raymond yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
hoit yes representative Lon yes
representative spear yes representative
Ryan yes and the chair
no okay that is 17 to three motion
passes 17 to three it goes
goes to the
floor
182 um that was three for three
Nos and the rest are one two three four
five
six
chair I mean 17 to three is that what I
said I voted no okay he is there a uh
okay does go to the floor who will be
uh representative Harvey Darby will be
writing the yeah I'll write the
committee
report is there any appetite for putting
this on consent do you want to debate it
h is there any appetite for putting this
on consent or do you want to debate it
okay maybe no if anybody wants a right
doable
no we'll put it this way if a Minority
Report shows up I'll tell I'll accept it
okay by by by by
Friday actually by by Sunday because I'm
review
okay that's it for now we have the only
is excuse
me the uh
going to going to Temp we're going to
close the hearing on
uh on we're going to close the executive
session I think we have a I think we
have a uh well we we have to take up 472
but before I close it we have to take up
472 uh for as a hearing the EXE the Don
gerain
amendment I thought there was an
addition
I maybe I missed it I don't have it is
there
another uh notice for the
472 uh
hearing okay I I just okay I just didn't
have okay all right I'll I'll close the
uh I'll close this executive session and
I'll open the public hearing session uh
section session on the
amendment to uh House Bill 472 which is
the amendment number uh
2284 and the chair recognizes
representative rung to speak that that
is your amendment is it not speak to the
amendment uh the non- gerain amendment
and the re the reason that it is
considered non- gerain is because it
uses a different uh portion different
portion of the of the statutes to uh
correct the issue so by definition it is
non jban according to the clerk and the
speaker
so be that the case that's what we're
here for we're to have the public this
is the public hearing on uh on this this
amendment thank you Mr chair um if we go
back in our memory to when this bill
first came before
resources um the prime sponsor
representative Crawford brought it
Forward at a constituent request the
constituent was very concerned that a
temporary dock was um jeopardizing the
nesting location of loons and during the
public hearing we heard from many people
and I apologize for not bringing my
notes from that executive session I mean
that public hearing with me but we heard
from several people who said that Lon
nests need to be
protected um that temporary dogs or
other structures can um uh limit alon's
ability to return to that nest because
they always return to the same nest so
there there was still some question
about whether the intent was going to be
accomplished through that bill so during
the summer I know representative Darby
met with fishing game I met with the
Loon Conservation Commission along or
the lon conservation committee along
with representative Crawford and um lo
and behold that we already see that in
statute there is a law that allows Fish
and Game to restrict boat traffic when
it is um threatening a nesting location
of an endangered species so this is
exactly the legislative intent but we in
addition to boats we need to include
other temporary we need to include
temporary structures like temporary
docks or um what I don't know if any of
You' have seen these on lakes now but
they have these big Inflatables that
come up it could be um like a rock
climbing wall could be a giant slide but
these are are Inflatables that are kept
up during the season in lakes and um we
want so instead of drafting new
legislation in a new area of Statute
that would restrict temporary dock
from threatening when when they're in a
position of threatening an endangered
species Nest we just want to uh amend
current statute that would Now read the
executive director May adopt and enforce
rules temporarily restricting boat
traffic that's already in law but we
would add or the use of temporary
seasonal docks and anchored seasonal
platforms so it would just expand Fish
and Game executive director to be able
to make judgments on whether those
structures or not are um uh would if the
director would deem necessary to protect
any threatened or endangered species of
wildlife in the earliest stages of life
so um I believe you know uh
representative Derby could speak to the
feedback he's had from fishing game but
this is something that is strongly
supported by the prime sponsor
representative Carol from Molton Boro
uh representative Crawford I'm sorry
from molteno and also um The Loon
conservation committee as per my
director any other discussion on the on
the amendment representative Darby thank
you Mr chair so I did speak on several
uh occasions to um commissioner price of
the fishing game um Department um
def I believe that we have a fishing
game representative here as well um the
you know as was testified at the um at
the work session Vision game is um I
wouldn't say they're in favor
necessarily of this however um and the
the language says may um adopt adopt an
enforce rules and as was pointed out
during the work session and I confirmed
they have not adopted any um any rules
restricting boat traffic however what
has happened and this is very important
is that the lon conservation committee
has um has worked in conjunction I guess
I'd say with fishing game and put up um
some notices to restrict um boat traffic
in very sensitive areas um and they did
it basically because of the enabling
legislation which is which is what is
being amended here which is what is
being updated here and so this um the
lon conservation committee is obviously
um committed to to preserving you know
an iconic species in our state um and
they they are well aware that um
bringing attention to Lun Nest is not
always the the best um option in fact it
sometimes it draws attention on the
other hand they um they use um they
apparently have have used that the
existing legislation to to help protect
the loons and this I believe strongly
believe that this legislation this
modification with respect to uh
temporary seasonal docks and uh anchored
seasonal platforms would um would give
them more um encouragement to protect
loons in these areas as well as they see
fit in conjunction with fishing game so
even if we hear in a minute that fishing
game is not going to Draft rules rules
to support um you know to um to to sort
of enforce this themselves it will
really enable I believe the lon uh
conservation committee um preservation
committee sorry to um to um provide
better support to um uh better um sort
of safety for Lon nests um and as we
heard in the original testimony 50% of
Lun Nest fail so it is it is this is
important um this is an important bill
um to continue to restore this this um
this great bird throughout our state
thank you very
much repres representative
Veil thank you Mr chair just to be
brief I watch the loons every summer on
the Loon preservation committee's Lon
Cam
and I just think this bill is perfect
does it is amended and it allows the
birds to defend their nests from normal
predators and not from human activity um
maybe we could get that nesting success
rate up if we're not so disruptive on
the shoreline where they do Nest um and
if you watch the lon cam you can just
see all the things that they have to
face between storms and wake boats and
the things that kind of wash out their
nest it's um incredible to watch them
fight for what they have and so I'm glad
that we're backing them up here um on
this bill in this committee because I
think it is a significant change to um
allow the Loon preservation committee to
continue its really good work and work
that it's done in concert with the state
not against the state but with the
state I remind the members of the
committee we are talking about the
amendment and not on the bill uh being
that said is there any other comments on
the
amendment seeing none I will close the
public hearing on the amendment and I
will open the public hearing on the
executive
session on House Bill for
72 uh is there any do I have a motion
representative rung thank you Mr
chairman I move um ought to pass on
House Bill
472 and you have an uh on the motion of
ought to pass like I I'm going to call
for an amendment
first oh well you you you move the
motion is there is there a second for
representative I'm happy a second don't
be too happy okay I don't want you too
happy go all
right okay Mr chair I now uh move an
amendment um amend mment number
2023 d22
84h and motion to uh on the amendment a
motion do I have a second are you going
to second that too sure
okay he seconds that all right on on the
on the on the
amendment will uh is there any more
discussion on the amendment to adapt it
no I just want to reiterate that
currently in statute which is RSA
212-a colon 2 allows the executive
director of fishing game to they may
adopt and enforce rules temporarily
restricting boat traffic the use of
temporary seasonal docks and anchored
seasonal platforms on any Waters of this
state as the executive director deems NE
necessary to protect any threatened or
endangered species of wildlife in the
earliest stages of life so it just adds
two more components in addition to boat
traffic that may threaten these nests
amendment just to speak to the amendment
is there any more discussion on House
Bill
472 as
amended seeing none will the CL please
is it on on the is it on was just on the
amendment I thought we had we haven't
voted on the amend oh we haven't voted
on the amendment excuse me this is just
on the amendment all right clerk please
call the rooll on the
amendment I just want to get out of here
2284 representative hark
yes representative voyd yes
representative Horgan yes clerk votes
yes representative kryon I
representative wal
yes
um representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale yes representative
Rong yes representative Kelly yes
representative Raymond yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
poit yes representative lontine yes
representative spear yes representative
Ryan yes and the chair uh yes then it's
20 to zero
okay on ought to pass as
amended representative
rung um I move ought to pass as amended
on House Bill
472 with have a second are you seconding
representative wolf yes sir
okay it once I'll do it all okay seeing
no more was no one else wish to this no
hands for discussion we've had enough
discussion will the clerk please call
the
role on ought to pass as amended ought
to pass as amended House Bill 472
representative harb yes representative
Boyd yes representative pgan yes
representative uh the clerk votes yes
representative Kon hi representative
wolf yes representative MC yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative
Kelly yes representative Raymond yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Hoy yes representative L montin yes
representative spier yes uh
representative Ryan yes and the
chair yes and that's 20 to zero un
unanimously passed is a unanimous
consent
okay that uh okay I'm going to close the
hearing I'm like to have a caucus of the
Republican caucus right after we close
the
uh uh the hearing is closed uh could you
clear the room for like to have a
republican those members who are sitting
in uh you could you're you're
excused uh the caucus of the regular
members
that